so when you visited the farm in
Tennessee I think the first time before
you all sat down have that conversation
with anime about making the documentary
were you already scouting out possibly
in your mind where you wanted to shoot
if you were asked back how did you plan
out your trip once you're there you say
it was just for an initial interview
well I think before you realize what to
shoot you have to get a sense of the
place and get a sense of the history I
mean what comes to mind when you say
that is that you know driving through
the farm we would pass this like rubble
pile of bricks why would you shoot a
rubble pile of bricks you don't know
what it is then over time at you here we
would hear these stories oh well that
was the old laundromat and at the peak
of our you know at the peak of the of
the commune the line would be around the
block and people would be there all
night long doing their laundry and you
would if you were a member of the
household and it was your turn to do
laundry would take the whole house is
laundry there you'd stay up all night
and do it so then all of a sudden that
becomes like something that you that
becomes part of the radar you know what
I mean and so especially because we were
dealing with the farm the landscape as
like sort of a character that sort of
informants we had to kind of get to know
like what what is this place I remember
when we went walking with Pamela through
the woods I was like that was what our
sect third trip third trailer yeah it
was summer yeah we also um had the idea
to visited in all four seasons and to
capture sort of that you know the
passage of time and and birth and review
no birth and death and sort of what that
the seasons can can convey but
summertime we went with Pamela and she
took us on this great walk in the woods
and and it was it was really for us this
like moment we were like oh we're going
deeper we're going deeper into the farm
somebody just took us on the pathways
that we didn't even know existed and she
took us up the ridge to this sort of
mossy place where she said that you know
a lot of very beautiful
things happen there because it's it is
sort of this removed hidden locale you
know but it took that many trips to get
to know her to get to go on the walk to
get to go further in the woods then we
would have ventured alone so it really
sort of unveiled its secrets to us as we
spent time there and as you're walking
you know through the woods it's like
there's a school bus that's just jammed
in there from the 70s it's so there's
this history you know it's all around
you there and you can't help but sort of
asked questions like wait who lived in
that bus and how did that get here and
you know um it's really interesting that
way so your plan was just sort of to get
the feel for the place not so much yeah
I mean we I remember when we first went
um you can sign up for a tour of the
farm and so doors every Thursday we
found this woman Vicky who gives the
farm tours and we drove around with her
and we filmed the whole thing like
thinking this was going to be you know
and none of that footage was used but um
it was it was really for us to sort of
understand that or what the land was
what everything was you know where
everything was and so that was kind of I
forgot about that yeah you have to get a
sense of place you know and she took us
to the Sun cemetery and I remember that
that that was like we realized in being
taken there you know it was like hard to
deny this connection between birth and
death like Sarah just mentioned and
throughout you know we we wanted to
include this wonderful scene that we had
in the cemetery but we didn't end up
including it in the film about inma you
know anime talks about the end of life
and the beginning of life and how
they're quite similar
you know and how they treat it there at
the farm and it didn't fit into the film
which was sort of heartbreaking but it
gives you a better idea of how they live
there and with such intention I thought
it was great to that you had anime on
her bike um I don't know she was like
riding past these solar panels yeah
those were put in while we were filming
oh when we first got there they weren't
there well I thought to it was a great
sort of metaphor in some sense of how
strong she is here she's on this bike
just kind of forging ahead yeah by
herself and then also her planting those
seedlings or whatever she had me in the
garden just showing how sort of
self-reliant she was yeah and I thought
that was great footage to probably
really established who she was you know
she got some really just beautiful shots
but also really helped to form an idea
from this one
you